[Música]
você já parou para analisar que a forma
como você vive hoje e realiza suas
tarefas cotidianas mudou muito em
relação às gerações passadas por exemplo
para pensar como era a forma de
comunicação na época da sua avó e como a
gente se comunica hoje muito
provavelmente na época da sua viola se
comunicavam por meio de cartas ou às
vezes tinha um telefone fixo em casa que
realizava algumas ligações telefônicas a
um preço altíssimo fazer um dvd biches
nem pensar
hoje em dia a gente tem um aparelho que
cabe na palma da nossa mão e dispara
mensagens em questões de segundos
praticamente todo mundo ou vão parar
para analisar o ambiente de trabalho
na época da sua avó grandes empresas
grandes indústrias tinham máquinas
pesadas
tinha muita gente em um mesmo ambiente
de trabalho fazendo processos de forma
100% manual
hoje em dia por muitas vezes a gente não
precisa nem está no mesmo ambiente de
trabalho da nossa equipe para entregá as
tarefas que nos foram dadas realmente
muita coisa mudou no mundo está mudando
em velocidade cada vez maiores até aqui
nenhuma novidade pra ninguém
afinal a gente já percebe isso no nosso
dia a dia a gente já percebe isso no
ambiente de trabalho a gente já vê as
notícias na tv falando sobre todas essas
mudanças mas eu quero que vocês pensem
em mais uma reflexão pensa como era a
sala de aula na época da sua avó e como
é a sala de aula hoje em dia pois é
apesar de todas as mudanças
um ponto muito importante segue
praticamente inalterado o nosso sistema
de ensino
a gente segue utilizando um sistema de
ensino que data da primeira revolução
industrial e que muito se assemelha à
fábrica daquela época
para pensar a gente continua fazendo com
que os nossos alunos sentem em fileiras
copia em matéria do quadro saiu pra
plancha só quando toca o sinal aprendam
matérias que muitas vezes não sabem onde
vão utilizar na vida e tudo isso sendo
avaliados por meio de provas pontuais
que avaliam a memória de curto prazo que
ele tem
ou seja o famoso decoreba e não tão
preocupado se ele aprendeu de fato
alguma coisa ou não eu posso que se você
perguntar para um aluno no dia seguinte
o que ele lembra da matéria muito
realmente lembra muito pouco
por outro lado a gente vê uma enxurrada
de reportagens tendências relatórios
apontando como deveria ser uma educação
do futuro uma educação mais prática mais
humanizada uma educação que tem o aluno
como um dos principais protagonistas
dessa história e mais alinhada com o
século atual
mas por que será que a gente continua
utilizando o mesmo sistema de ensino
apesar de todas essas mudanças porque a
gente só aponta tendências para amanhã
mais não faz quase nada hoje
foi buscando respostas para essas
perguntas que há oito anos atrás
após viver uma experiência impactante na
minha vida eu resolvi largar da
engenharia
sim eu sou formado em engenharia
elétrica para me dedicar a fundo no
mundo da educação trabalha como
professor voluntário em escolas públicas
na sibéria e de lá pra cá comecei a
buscar modelos que fizessem realmente
sentido não me prendendo a preconceitos
ou a linhas pedagógicas que me
obrigassem a seguir por aí
meu grande objetivo era aprender novos
modelos e ver o que trazia resultado na
prática para esses alunos
de lá pra cá empreende dezenas de
projetos na área de educação não tem
empresas
trabalhei com jovens e trabalho com
jovens e adultos com executivos e
pessoas analfabetas
trabalhei em grandes centros urbanos em
favelas em zonas rurais e até mesmo em
zonas de conflito armado e descobri que
mesmo em contextos tão diversos e
públicos tão diferentes
alguns desafios se repetiam e que sim
era possível a gente propor um novo
modelo de educação que ajudasse a gente
a dar os primeiros passos para essa tão
sonhada educação do futuro que eu quero
compartilhar com vocês são os meus três
principais aprendizados dessa jornada
o primeiro aprendizado é que apesar de
todo avanço da tecnologia ela não deve
ser visto com uma solução final
ela tem que ser um meio uma ferramenta
não adianta nada a gente ter uma lousa
digital um óculos de realidade virtual
ou tablets ea gente continuar utilizando
o mesmo sistema de ensino fazendo o
aluno copiar as matérias do quadro e
decorar informações com uma prova
modelos mais práticos mas vamos lá
massas com objetivos claros é muito mais
eficiente do que o que a gente tem hoje
enquanto a gente não começar a rever o
sistema de ensino ea romper certos
paradigmas
a gente vai continuar tendo uma
distância gigantesca entre o que tem
dentro da sala de aula e o que é cobrado
no mundo ou no mercado de trabalho e
isso me faz lembrar o segundo grande
aprendizado que é com exceção de algumas
profissões e conhecimentos em específico
hoje em dia é muito mais do que um
diploma formal o que mais vale é a
experiência que tem a experiência que
você tem é o que o torna único frente às
outras pessoas e para você adquirir essa
experiência não necessariamente você
precisa ter o diploma for mal muito pelo
contrário
descobri que hoje em dia a gente tem uma
infinidade de possibilidades diferentes
de aprender de uma forma muito mais
divertida e muito mais prazerosa
por exemplo eu queria aprender como
criar um chat bote aqueles programas de
computador que simula um ser humano em
uma conversação caminho tradicional
seria fazer uma faculdade na área de ti
e ou um curso longo na área de
programação ou eu poderia hackear o
sistema e criar o meu próprio curso
comecei ali está as diversas
possibilidades que eu tinha pra aprender
como criar um chat bote
procurei cursos livres vídeos no youtube
podcast x ativos de ponta que muito
provavelmente vocês não vão encontrar em
nenhum curso de graduação por aí e com
isso eu criei o meu próprio mb enchete
bote algo que se adequava muito mais ao
meu perfil ao meu tempo e recursos
disponíveis e você já parou para pensar
em quais possibilidades você tem pra
aprender alguma coisa sobre essa
possibilidade por exemplo de materiais
gratuitas na internet fazer uma
assinatura de uma revista de um portal
ou até mesmo comprar uma passagem aérea
de volta ao mundo que eu posso garantir
para vocês ser muito mais barata e muito
mais impactante que muito curso de
pós-graduação porém eu sei que alguns
podem se questionar ou duvidado que eu
tô falando mas no fundo todos nós
sabemos quem é que vai levar aquela tão
sonhada vaga de emprego
muito provavelmente vai ser aquela
pessoa mais criativa que sabe trabalhar
em equipe utilizar os recursos
disponíveis e não necessariamente aquela
pessoa que teve as melhores notas na
faculdade mas não sabe como dar o
primeiro passo sozinho quando pára pra
pensar sobre isso me vem o terceiro
aprendizado que é um elemento chave para
que a gente possa aproveitar todas essas
oportunidades que é necessário sermos
mais protagonistas
enquanto a gente continua apontando o
dedo e buscando o culpado
a recopa do governo a culpa da crise é
culpa da família
o chefe da empresa do cachorro enfim a
gente não vai sair do lugar
a gente precisa ser mais protagonista a
gente começa a gente tem que dar os
primeiros passos
ao longo dessa jornada conhecido no
mundo inteiro pessoas e projetos
fantásticos que realmente fazem
acontecer mas também conheci muita gente
acomodada que senta em cima dos seus
desafios cruza os braços e espera um
milagre acontecer se tornaram pessoas
especialistas em apontar o dedo e buscar
um culpado do alto das redes sociais
como diria o tio ben o tio do homem
aranha com grandes poderes vêm grandes
responsabilidades
se você vê um problema algo que te
inquieta
você tem o poder de começar a pensar em
soluções para aquilo que eu penso isso
eu lembro uma ótima história quando
estava aprendendo a esquiar na rússia eu
me perguntava também como é que eu daria
os meus primeiros passos na educação ao
voltar para o brasil
eu ficava pensando assim poxa mas quem
sou eu um jovem engenheiro recém-formado
querendo fazer alguma coisa na área de
educação
e aí teve um momento que foi muito
marcante estou numa grande filosofia pra
mim
um belo dia nunca esqueça o meu pai
russo e morava em uma casa de família
ele chegou para mim e falou assim
falando você até leva jeito pra esquiar
nossa o que está acontecendo é que você
tá com medo
você tá com medo de cair quando na
verdade a queda o erro faz parte do
aprendizado
mas se você começar a ir sem medo você
vai começar a perceber que você vai
começar a acertar muito mais errar muito
menos quando falou isso me deu um clique
tão grande que eu comecei a rever muita
coisa na minha vida
por isso sempre que bater aquele medinho
vocês
você fica na dúvida se você deve ou não
tirar aquele aquela idéia do papel
like goiá depôs na china nunca tenha
medo de começar
obrigado
[Aplausos]